insgesamt und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch jedes gut wir haben uns
heute mal wieder hier versammelt um ein
neues wie sollte es auch anders sein
unboxing video für euch zu drehen ich
muss nämlich sagen falls ihr euch daran
erinnert ich habe letztens für 300 euro
amazon retouren gekauft bei ebay das
team richtig ab also ich hab damit denke
ich schon über 1000 euro verdient also
habe ich guten gewinn gemacht hätte ich
vorher niemals erwartet weil ich auch
nicht wusste auch alles funktioniert in
parramatta effekt trotzdem unterm strich
hat sich das gelohnt deswegen habe ich
einfach nochmal neues paket bestellt
wieder so was ähnliches vielleicht habe
ich diesmal noch mehr glück deshalb
glaube ich ein bisschen mehr gekostet
als letztes mal übrigens wenn ihr bock
habt dass ich mal zeigen was ich mit
diesen ganzen restposten sachen bis
jetzt verdient habt könnt ihr sogar
gerne doch nach oben da lassen dann
mache ich das mal auf meinem anderen
kanal alex baur was geht übrigens diese
lampe funktioniert nicht und diese lampe
funktioniert die lampe ist kaputt musste
neuling 1
naja ich zeige euch mal kurz was
angekommen ist hier ein kurzer
ausschnitt von heute morgen
so leute neue amazon palette neues glück
können jetzt kann ich endlich mal putzen
hier ganz neues prozent das ist doch
schon mal nicht schlecht und so neu ist
es doch nicht ich habe das ganze
netterweise schon mal hier hoch gebracht
wir haben hier einmal wieder drei fette
kartons von amazon 123 das war ein guter
beat und dann gehen wir noch mal nach
hinten und ich zeige euch weitere sachen
wie zum beispiel dieses paket keinen
plan was da drin ist das wird schon mal
von dpd verschickt hinzu kommt dieses
ding ein kindersitz fürs auto und ein
kinderwagen allerdings defekt wie kann
ein kinderwagen defekt sein vielleicht
geht eine rolle nicht keine ahnung und
dann mal wieder so ein dummes
bettgestell aber keine angst es brauche
halt nicht leute ich habe bock wir
starten direkt mal schreibt super gerne
in die kommentare was ich noch bestellen
soll alles und könnt ihr auch kein
fenster
33 alex wie folgt auf instagram wer
nicht folgt ist kein voller junger mann
eis wir starten jetzt dass man sich
direkt schon mal ein bisschen
runterfahren sondern sieht man mich ja
gar nicht mehr
ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau im
letzten video hatten wir glaube ich
sogar noch einen amazon karton mehr das
sind ja echt immer große kartons und ich
bin einfach mal gespannt ob wir hier was
holen haben womit man viel geld
verdienen kann
oder halt zumindest so viel geld wie
beim letzten mal da würde ich mich auf
jeden fall schon mit zufrieden geben das
waren mich sehr nice ok also ihr seht ja
die kartons sie hier drin sind sind sehr
hart demoliert hier haben wir schon mal
ein wischmopp ja den habe ich heute
morgen ganz oben drauf auch schon
gefunden also einer davon steht auch
noch da hinten das heißt wir haben jetzt
höre ich schon drei sind die kaputte
oder was kann denn also ermisch nur
kaputt gehen eigentlich nicht viel und
ich hoffe dass manche vielleicht oder
mache ich sofort auch mal einen
wischmopp hier haben wir dann auch ein
das ist das denn nach so dass es für
rotlicht ich weiß nicht ob man sich
damit freuen kann
santas sanitas in verbund landwirt wenn
man krank ist wenn man hier so ein
bisschen hier diese schnupfen drin hat
dann kann man das super verwenden geiles
produkt das habe ich auch schon ewig
benutze ich das selber und dann haben
wir hier also dieser karton ist einen
moving boards stell dich mal kurz nach
hinten dann einmal noch dieses dringend
das müssen wir gleich mal aufmachen und
nach eurer paraffin barth habe ich noch
nie gesehen so was wobei ich lebe schon
was nicht so gutes hier steht drauf geht
nicht an
das heißt man kann es auch nicht
loswerden jetzt schaue ich mir das an
mal sehen ob das gesagte noch
vollständig ist
das sieht doch so aus ein paar meter das
ist ihr seht ihr die preise wie man hier
eingeblendet aber ich denke damit kann
man vielleicht 15 euro verdienen
bestellen dass man schnell beiseite und
holen den nächsten karton also hier
haben wir auf jeden fall was für die
kids einmal kinder
und einmal kinderwagen genommen ich
frage mich was damit also warum benutzt
man das denn nicht das sieht einfach aus
wie ein ganz normaler kindersitze kam
raus eintopf kindern keine ahnung wieso
der ball landet hier aber das ist doch
geil irgendwie irgendwie riecht ein
bisschen komisch dieser kinder sind als
hätte da ein kind drauf gibt also es
riecht schon nicht so gut das muss ich
sagen fairerweise sagen das ist ein
zeichen heißt das denn also ich hab hier
auf amazon gefunden aktuell nicht aufs
tor
wir hatten 100 euro gekostet keine
ahnung also bin werde ich bestimmt wo es
dann haben wir hier tritt auch einen
defekten kinderwagen
ich habe irgendwie angst wenn ich dir
jetzt auspacken dass ich da nicht mehr
rein bekommen obwohl eigentlich müsste
das schaffen aber wenn das schon perfekt
drauf steht lohnt sich das den ausschlag
ich weiß nicht jetzt erst mal nicht fürs
video wir machen mit diesen beiden
kartons weiter weil da hab ich bock
drauf
heute morgen war irgendwie leichter und
in anderen hole ich auch direkt dazu
dann können wir zwei gleichzeitig aus
konnten
hui der ist ja von unten bis oben
gefüllt mit tollen also ich freue mich
dass jetzt nicht aber ich glaube es gibt
menschen die so was brauchen wir packen
zusammen aus als erstes haben wir hier
einen roboter pick wörter floss das
dingen kann klinisch nachgewiesen
irgendwann gab es ist das habe ich noch
nie gesehen die einfache und effektive
methode zur reinigung der
zahnzwischenräume okay da kommt also
wasserhaus für die zahnzwischenräume das
könnte ich mir jetzt auch perfekt wenn
das schon mal jemand vorher benutzen war
es das wurde vorher schon mal benutzt
geil deswegen stelle ich das direkt auch
hierzu dass wir jetzt
kommt nächsten sin restposten paket ok
weiter geht hiermit das hier ist einfach
ich glaube dass mit kannst du auch
nichts mehr anfangen oder also dann
könnte ich mich ja schon wieder aufregen
was die leute zurückschicken
was ist das ja hier fehlt was dort mit
müll nächster sport vielleicht kann man
es doch reparieren also ich nicht aber
vielleicht jeder von euch dann haben wir
hier ein rochat mir fällt auf selbst
findet dieser sachen kommen anscheinend
aus frankreich ich glaube das war beim
letzten paket auch schon so das liegt
halt daran bei amazon frankreich nicht
in amazon weiterverkauft sondern alle
sachen diese restposten retouren werden
ins ausland geschickt genauso ist es in
deutschland auch weswegen hier
wahrscheinlich kaum deutsche sachen drin
sein werden also ihr seht ihr hier immer
die neupreise eingeblendet muss ich
gucken ob das ding noch irgendwie
einsatzbereit ist dann haben wir hier
ein
das ist schön ein massage kopfkissen das
kannst du unter deinem kopf legen
klickten knopf und wer ist dann schön
das pulver aus
das nehme ich direkt mit nach hause und
weiter geht's bonding hatte ich schon
mal das habe ich damals bei mich
bestellt ihr könnt sie sehen ein amt
viel multi function ewigen medienmanager
kannst du so rumliegt und deine
schultern und dann wirst du schön
passiert eigentlich ganz gut ich weiß
die dinger sind nicht allzu teuer liegen
so 30 bis 50 euro
trotzdem danke dafür made in china h
dann haben wir hier einmal eine
elektrische zahnbürste die ist noch neu
verpackt waren bestimmt eingestaubt aber
ja danke dafür
das gleiche haben wir das ist wieder so
ein zahnreinigung sting also das hier
ist anscheinend eine zahnrettungsbox
manche sachen das könnte auch was da
kannst du irgendwie also das ist eine
online nehme sei auch so irgendwas für
die nase
ich dachte damit kann vielleicht waren
es auch kommen ja irgendwie alles das
gleiche
solche sachen habe ich noch nie gesehen
auch hier haben wir von nokia ein reines
pressure monitor hey nokia damit kannst
du deinen blutdruck messen oder kostet
hier 790 euro und ihr sogar einer für
215 euro noch nicht schlecht dann haben
wir hier noch eine reihe von grundig aus
gutem grund das hat er wirklich drauf
das kann dann irgendwie meinen kopf
amazon steht er auch aus gutem grunde
habe hat sich dann diesen kreativen
marketing vorausgegangen profi hast
deine hs ab 1980 gegen die hat sich das
solar an
da fehlt er die hälfte der scheiße es
manchmal wirklich du kannst es dir nicht
ausmalen irgendwelche speisten bestellen
das bei amazon bauen das auseinander
bauen das dann zur hälfte wieder herein
schicken das zurückkriegen ihr geld
wieder und das lernen per live-ticker
dass das überhaupt das ist einfach ein
witz wie frisch können menschen sein
oder wie sehen meine videos und wollte
ich einfach nur ärgern kann ich auch
nichts mit anfangen dann haben wir hier
nur auf ein planetarium okay und hier
noch ein wärme unterwelt also wenn euch
manchmal nachts kalt ist dann könnt ihr
das unter bett legen und durch wird
nicht mehr als problem gelöst der rest
ist halt alles nur noch diese
zahnreinigung skarke die wir hier schon
30 mal stehen haben
deswegen machen wir uns mal auf zu
diesem paket alter das ist so krass tief
überzeugt da immer zusammen kommen denn
so box mit kann man hier ist einfach
alles voll gestellt wir machen die
letzte auf und ich hoffe mal das ist
jetzt auch die beste weil es war auf
jeden fall die schwerste aber vielleicht
sind ja auch nur steine bringen wer weiß
sagt oh mein gott tiger schillig das ist
auf jeden fall schon mal 1 das ist aber
auch alles verstaut waren
ich kann auf jeden fall meine sachen
gleich ausziehen also und dann halt was
neues ansehen denn das hier klar für die
jahre ich mal ein placement ich weiß
nicht ob das gut ist oder nicht happy
brass kennt man doch oder von die höhle
der löwen sogar das wusste ich gar nicht
hier scheint es so zu sein als wer lebt
viele zahnreinigung dinger drin war das
ist halt wirklich dann ein bisschen rand
sich das weiter zu verkaufen weil wer
möchte zahnbürste
haben die vielleicht schon mal irgendwo
in benutzung ich jedenfalls nicht aber
checken wir doch mal diese happy brass
aus vielleicht ist ja frisch
guck mal leute ihr könnt ihr sehen die
wurde noch nicht verwendet und so ein
ding kostet schnell auch mal 50 60 70
euro glaube ich zumindest
dann haben wir hier ein kurator scannt
man doch dann haben wir hier ein dildo
ok nein das heißt vakuum blackhat
premiere vor das klingt auch schon
leicht eklig hier noch ein set für
zahnbürsten und dann ganz wtf ganz viel
bettwäsche oder was ist das hier haben
wir noch eine bürste die bis 230 grad
kann man die erhitzen ach so und dann
kann man die haare wahrscheinlich leicht
erkennen schauen wir mal kurz rein also
die sieht auf jeden fall noch
funktionsfähig aus und ganz gut
also ich weiss ich hier haben wir ein
kissen oder das ist eine decke kann man
bestimmt auch irgendwie loswerden und
dann hier noch so ein sitzkissen wo ich
noch mal durchgeführt wurde
hier wurde wirklich durch jedes kissen
geburt oder da musste man eine schraube
reihe drehen aber die kannste ja so
keinen mehr anbieten und dann haben wir
hier unten noch einen ventilator
zumindest war das mal ein ventilator ich
hier noch irgendwelche seite und alles
stinkt das war auf jeden fall einen flop
also ich will gar nicht wissen in
welchem jahr 1000 das an amazon
zurückgeschickt wurde wahrscheinlich
nicht in diesem so zügig doch dies ist
dann kommen wir jetzt leider auch schon
zum letzten paket das ist dieses hier
ich glaube hier ist ihren ab drin also
wahrscheinlich aus und gestellt
habt ihr es gesehen also wer das ungern
komplett raus ziehen das ist ein
babybett es gibt ja riesige lager heiter
sind nur so retouren drin irgendwelche
schicken babybett zurück das muss ja
auch alles irgendwie dahin tragen dann
wieder weg tragen also die vielen
paketen boden täglich tragen da muss man
auch einfach macht den längsten applaus
gab
na ja ich wollte mir jetzt erst mal auf
dann werde ich das mal ein bisschen
zusammen rechnet das letzte paket war
glaube ich besser aber wir haben wieder
unglaublich viel ware und das muss ich
jetzt erst mal wieder loswerden bis
später leute was geht wir haben schon
den nächsten tag und ich hatte ein
bisschen zeit alles zusammen zu richten
man muss sagen es ist immer so
unscheinbar manche sachen dann plötzlich
richtigen wert da denkst die sodinger
als wenn das teil 100 euro kostet
deswegen waren wir gar nicht so schlecht
unterwegs ich habe alles mal
zusammengerechnet und sachen die
offensichtlich schon unvollständig waren
gar nicht mit einbrüchen bei einfach
1315 euro natürlich sind das alles
retouren weswegen ich jetzt hier wieder
mal 0,6 also mal 0,6 40 prozent abziehen
gleich wieder bei 789 euro ja gar nicht
so schlecht und ohne scheiß ich hab bei
dem letzten video mit den ganzen sachen
so knapp 1000 euro verdient deswegen bin
ich da wieder ganz gut guter dinge ihr
könnt da vorne sehen das sind zwei
schrottkisten damit kann man sich nicht
mehr viel anfangen die meisten sachen
den effekt den das gibt es bei lucky dog
ii.de aber jetzt super gerne den kanal
und dank fürs zuschauen heute wir sehen
uns die tage wieder ganz neues kleines
video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen